[Music]
[Music]
you dare enter this [ __ ] house
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey did here New York City final
[ __ ] night
you're asking yourself is uncle Joey
ready what is he doing right now is a
pregame maneuver I'm [ __ ] writing my
jokes down whatever the [ __ ] I got those
stupid things and I'm over here smoking
vapors you know me that you reek of bait
the plan always the best this one's a
pure [ __ ] indica this one here the
deadly understand me
I mean don't get me wrong I got Arif I'm
a man of many reasons I got Skywalker
and The Devil's laugh we always got the
[ __ ] blood red stars you know me too
we don't go nowhere without these
[ __ ] things okay while we celebrate
the [ __ ] Sun look like a car
dealership it always a sale [ __ ] 200
400 600 800 no going deep in the murky
waters glad I know about six dollars
that's 1200 [ __ ] milligrams I'm gonna
blast these boat before these shows but
it's all over these things some blood
pressure medication there's some
nicotine gum you ain't stopping me I'm
saying you ain't [ __ ] stopping that's
just the way it is it's been a fun four
days here man it's good to go home you
gotta go home from time to time you
gotta walk the steps and went on my
grandma school I put my mother's grave I
went to the park I looked at the rocket
ship I slept under as a [ __ ] reminder
that I could change all in one [ __ ]
minute cuz you can change all in one
minute that's why you gotta keep a piece
of your bad time man your mind in the
corner you gotta check up on those
[ __ ] skeletons from time to time is a
[ __ ] reminder [ __ ]
but Joey enough with the chitty-chat hit
that [ __ ] vapor Pat you know me dog
I'm a man of many vapors
don't worry you don't mean I got backup
tubes and I got a tube for the backup -
you always gotta be prepared you
understand me if you're not prepared
shits gonna come up and there you are
with your dick in your head it's like me
I got rolling papers everywhere I take
them out fold them into little [ __ ]
spit balls and hide them all over
everywhere my love is everything you
don't even want to see them see rolling
papers as a whole cuz that opens up the
[ __ ] gap of thought you always want
to get your real rolling papers and take
them out and roll them into little flock
the script wolf and just throwing around
your suitcase don't go what the [ __ ] is
this guy - they don't know what a flunky
think if they're telling you this [ __ ]
for six [ __ ] years but nobody listens
look at me over here living like
Thurston Howell the [ __ ] third
smoking skinny cigarettes but it don't
matter cuz the action continues today
730 10 o'clock Gotham comedy club sold
out out of respect New York City I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart
understand me
Boston we don't matter whoever we go the
church is [ __ ] this if you show up a
bad ideas you're gonna get your head
chopped off there's a church they're
worse than [ __ ] Isis they don't [ __ ]
around
what I need now is a cup of tea and
three little [ __ ] jumping around saying
Chelsea ChIP chip cheerio and I got
myself a little [ __ ] International
Tea Party ha ha ha and what do you think
about the global situation
I just had my last supper I have some
Cuban food from my favorite place a van
a [ __ ] cafe in Edgewater I had
to pick I leave you a little idea
forget about I'm gonna primed up and
ready to deal with those gluten-free
kelp even [ __ ] Momo zobelle ate them
Monday or tomorrow but that's it and
that's that I got to see my good friends
I got to see my family I got to see
people were there when I was talking
living under a [ __ ] rocket ship those
people they're the ones that matter they
were there from nothing $3.00 is a
dollar in my pocket when I was shirt
ripped and [ __ ] blood coming out of
my nose
deep into murky waters machine my
keyboard tonight daddy I'm gonna see
[ __ ] the Holloway clan the father and
the two little [ __ ] Halle wets it's
all over I'm gonna see my family tonight
so I'm very excited Mike from the
jewelry store
and as usual I'm stopped there's no more
to [ __ ] say I'll blast off with you
guys from the green room or something
later when we kill the rest of these
[ __ ] stars and that's it and that's
that I love you [ __ ] are all my
heart what are you guys and have nothing
you understand me that's why I do this
[ __ ] we smoke we're a [ __ ] family
[ __ ] the rest of these [ __ ] idiots
and that's it I love you cops uppers
thank you for selling out got to be for
me man
you're [ __ ] doing it for me I ain't
doing [ __ ] I'm just being myself you
guys are filling the gap so I appreciate
you with all my [ __ ] heart from the
bottom to my fat little fun guy talk I
love you [ __ ] be safe tonight
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you and keep
your eyes up
things are bad ol way or get that mummy
my bingo here sounds